اعمال الشخص الواحد الزهر في تسعه عشره
دوله حول العالم هي شركات الجديده التي
يملك راس مالها بالكامل شخص واحد فقط دون
ان يضيف اي موظف على كشوف المرتبات في
غضون السنوات الخمس الاولى التقرير الصادر
عن جلوبال وهي دراسه عالميه تهدف الى
تحليل مستوي رياده الاعمال في مجموعه من
البلدان الدراسه حللت نشاط الاعمال منذ
2019 وحتى 20 22 في 51 اقتصاد مشارك و173
الف شخص وجدت ان الدول امريكا الجنوبيه
مثل كولومبيا وتشيلي في المقدمه في اطار
نسبه البالغين الذين يؤسسون ويديرون شركه
جديده اما الاسباب الرئيسيه بحسب نتائج
فهي تحقيق الثروات وكسب لقمه العيش في ظل
تضاؤل فرص العمل واحداثي فارقا في المجتمع
بالاضافه الى مواصله الارث او النشاط
العائلي
بحسب نتائج دراسه عالميه جاءت دوله
الامارات على راس قائمه 12 دوله ارتفع
فيها نشاط رياده الاعمال بنسبه بلغت 12%
ثم تليها كولومبيا السعوديه وقطر وتايوان
والهند وهولندا وسويسرا وكوريا الجنوبيه
ضمن الاعلى تسجيلا للانشطه التجاريه
وشركات الشخص الواحد الخدمات الاستهلاكيه
هي الاكثر شيوعا عند اطلاق مشروع جديد
وتمثل ثلثي الشركات الناشئه الجديده في
اربعين من اصل 49 دوله في الخليج وامريكا
اللاتينيه يتبنى رواد الاعمال التقنيات
الرقميه الحديثه في اداره اعمالهم الصغيره
بمعدلات اعلى من المناطق الاخرى حول
العالم في السعوديه يؤمن 90% من المواطنين
بانفسهم وقدراتهم لتاسيس عمل تجاري اما
اليابان فتحتل المرتبه الادنى في هذا
السياق بين الدول المشاركه يميل الرجال
لتاسيس الاعمال التجاريه اكثر من النساء
باستثناء اربع دول وهي اندونيسيا بولندا
قطر وتوجو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من عمان ينضم لنا الخبر اقتصادي عامر
الشوبك هي سيد عامر اهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه نتحدث عن ارتفاع كبير حول العالم
لاعداد المشاريع الاقتصاديه التي يديرها
الشخص واحد على سبيل المثال وليس الحصر
عمان ارتفاع ب71% والمانيا بتسعه
بالاعمال الاقتصاديه والمشاريع التي
يديرها شخص واحد ما السبب في ذلك سبب هذا
الارتفاع
تحيه لك يسعد صباحك وصباح جميع المشاهدين
لك هذا الامر لم يكن متوقعا الا انه بعد
الثوره الصناعيه الاخيره وانتظار الثوره
الصناعيه الخامسه في الواقع في العالم
الذكاء الاصطناعي جائحه كورونا التي مرت
في الماضي ايضا واختلاف الموازين حيث لم
تعد التكنولوجيا
وطرق الاتصال السريعه فقط مقتصره على
الدول المتقدمه لذلك نرى هذا التقدم في
الدول العربيه الدول الخليج المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في الواقع تحتل المرتبه
الاولى في ثلاث
مبارات او ثلاث اتجاهات
لرياده الاعمال في العالم خاصه في
المشاريع الشخصيه
والفرديه للمواطنين المركبه المرتبه
الاولى في مثلا
اتجاه الشباب
او فرصتهم في انجاح اعمال جديده
اعتقاد الشباب بشكل جازم بان فرصتهم ستكون
ناجحه اذا ما انشاوا اعمال فرديه ومؤسسات
فرديه وشخصيه وذلك كما ذكرت لك لعوامل
التقدم التكنولوجي والعوامل الاجتماعيه
التي طرات على العالم بعد جائحه كورونا
يعني اسئله فكره السعوديه وسوق العمل
بالنسبه للشباب واليوم كمان هي بتحتل يعني
من المرتبه الاولى فيما يتعلق بمساله
التخارج للشركه اذا شخص اليوم عمل شركه ما
وهو اسسها يعني زي ما حكينا السولو بزنس
هل اليوم يعني انه طموحه في المستقبل ان
يتم شراء هذه الشركه يعني لا يريد ان يبقى
وحده الى الابد
لا لا اعتقد ذلك يعني هو اساسا عندما ينجح
مؤسسه الفرديه يكون بناء على انها ستكون
مؤسسه له خاصه فيبدع فيها يتحدى ساعات
فيها يعني بس على سبيل المثال يعني مثلا
سوء دوت كوم شراها مثلا امازون اوبر
وكريم عده مشاريع نعم عده مشاريع حققت
ارباح يعني عند انجاح هذا المشروع وعندما
يرى المنشئ بان هذا المشروع سوف يحقق له
ربح يعوضه عن التعب الذي بدله في البدايه
او اكثر من هذا التعب فبالتالي يعني بيع
المشروع هو مربح بالنسبه له وبعدها قد
يعني يفكر بشكل جدي لبناء مشروع جديد هذا
يحدث في دول العالم وحدث ايضا مع ايلون
ماسك الان اغنى يعني الرجال على وجه الارض
واغنى يعني البشر على وجه الارض من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه الى عماده السوق قياده
الاعمال او رواد الاعمال يمثلون حلا حيويا
قد يصلح الاقتصادات المتضرره في البلدان
التي تتاثر كثيرا بالتحولات في السوق
وتغير نظام اقتصادي والمالي بشكل مستمر
نعم شكرا سؤالك مهم جدا الان رياده
الاعمال والمؤسسات الفرديه هي التي تعول
عليها التكنولوجيا التكنولوجيا اصبحت
حصتها من الاقتصاد العالمي حصه كبيره
فلذلك المؤسسات الفرديه يعني لديها
الكثير من ما تضعوا او تضيفوا على الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي لاي بلد
فمثلا اذا ما اردنا المقارنه قطاع
التكنولوجيا الذي كان لا يتخطى الواحد
بالمئه قبل عشرين سنه من الاقتصاد العالمي
الان يتخطى العشرين بالمئه لذلك نقول بان
رياده الاعمال والمؤسسات الفرديه خاصه
التكنولوجيه منها والتي تعتمد عليها
الثوره الصناعيه المنتظره الخامسه
نتوقع بان يكون لها تقريبا نصف الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي لبعض من الدول
واصبحت
الاقتصاديات الكلاسيكيه مثل مثلا تج اره
النفط الذهب او التجاره العامه اصبحت تاخذ
نسبه اقل من التجاره العامه في العالم او
نسبه اقل من حجم الاقتصاد العالمي شركات
تكنولوجيا الان هي التي تسيطر على اسواق
المال هي التي يعني من يمتلكون هذه
الشركات هم الذين الان يتربعون على عرش
قمه الاغنياء في العالم نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك من عمل الخبر الاقتصادي
عامر شوبكي شكرا لك